for four years leon dash followed the
lives of rosalie cunningham her eight
children and five grandchildren the
pulitzer prize-winning journalist sat
down for a book notes interview in 1996
to discuss the resulting biography which
uses rosalie's personal story as a
representation of a growing underclass
in urban america the program is an hour
yeah who was rosalie cunningham
rosalie cunningham was a woman that i
met in the d.c jail in january 1988
and who i followed until her death of
aids prom aides in july 1995.
who's the fellow in the picture here
that's her oldest son he also died of
aids he died in january bobby bobby
cunningham he died in january 1994.
why did you do this book i was
interested in what's happening with the
underclass the american underclass i had
read studies by the urban institute that
said that the underclass in size has
tripled in the united states since 1970
and i was interested in the reasons why
and why it was perpetuating itself why
this poverty
very deep into stressful poverty and as
well as criminal deviancy was going on
from one generation to the next
so i went into the dc jail literally in
the summer of 1987
and interviewed over an 18-month period
20 men and 20 women who inmates who fit
the profile the urban institute had
established of what constitutes an
underclass family
and in that process i also met rosalie
cunningham i selected four families to
follow
three of the families were dropped for
um
it just became
impossible to follow four families at
one time and i concentrated solely on
rosalie's family from
september of 1990
until the series was published by the
washington post in september of 94.
then i took a leave of absence to write
a book about her and her family
where was rosalie cunningham born
here in washington d.c october 7 1936
she was born a year after her parents
and her grandparents arrived here they
were sharecroppers who came out of a
deep rural isolation in northampton
county in north carolina
a section just north of the north bank
of the roanoke river they had been on
the bishop and powell plantation at
least since
they were emancipated as slaves in 1863
and they left that area because of the
depression had forced down prices for
the major cash crops of that area were
peanuts groundnuts and cotton
and
the person that they were working for on
the plantation lost the plantation
because of the depression so they might
ended up migrating to washington
looking for work and a better life
how many times did she marry
once she married when she was 16 years
old she was pregnant with her third
child
a man named alvin cunningham
and
[Music]
the man who was the father of the child
married her because rosalie's mother
told the man he was then 21 albert
cunningham that if he did not marry her
she would inform the police because
rosalie was underage how many children
did she have in her life
she had eight children with five
different six different men six
different men
and
what's their
basic outline on those eight children
where are they today
oh today
um the oldest as we've mentioned bobby
he died of aids in
1994 january 1994.
the second born
ronald wright
works as a cook in a suburban maryland
restaurant and lives in an abandoned
house in southeast washington he's both
a heroin and crack addict
a criminal recidivist
the third born alvin
just recently became a station master in
the metro rail system but has been had
been before that a metro bus driver
since 1980
and then the
one that follows alvin richard
cunningham he was
a couple years ago shipped off to an
inpatient drug treatment facility in
denver colorado but violated parole and
is now back in the d.c prison system at
the central prison in lawton
virginia and after richard is eric eric
works for the u.s park service which he
does today and lives in suburban
maryland
after eric is patty patty is in prison i
just recently saw her
and she has now moved in she was hiv
positive when she was arrested in
connection with a murder in 1992
december of 1992
but she's now moved into full-blown aids
every day is a question of whether or
not she can get out of bed she is at
times so weak and so ill how old is she
now um
she was born in 1958 and
this is 36.
38 38 yeah
uh and
then after
patty
is
ducky rosalie's youngest son
he is in jail
a long-term
crack addict and petty thief he's
presently in jail
and then her youngest daughter
who asked that her name not be used in
connection with the book or with
anything that i write
she is in her sixth
year of recovery from a long-term period
of heroin and crack addiction crack
cocaine addiction
how many different places in washington
did rosalie live she lived in 18
different places over her lifetime twice
in shelters for the homeless
she grew up in poverty very deep poverty
here in washington
and never really got out of it either
her her dwellings were either slum
housing or public housing
uh
of the 18 places that she lived in
including the two homeless shelters
how did you go about doing this
um i use a methodology where you're
supposed to
i try to get as close to the people that
i'm interviewing as close as possible
spend a lot of time with them
many repeated interviews uh over the
same material over and over again
because from experience i've learned
that you don't really begin to get the
truth
of a circumstance or a person's life
from that person
until you've known that person for at
least four to six months
and generally then they begin to
really open up about their motivations
and the kinds of things that have
created their outlook on life
there's a picture we were just showing
here of you and rosalie ware
at a mcdonald's at
first and new york avenue northeast
where we spent a lot of time she went to
a methadone clinic there near there
every day every morning to get her
methadone dose to block her craving for
heroin
and we would generally meet there with
other people who also frequented the
methadone clinic
um people that she had known for for
most of her life
and
who also were heroin addicts and now on
methadone and everyone would gather
there after they got their methadone to
have breakfast
because almost all of them could not
keep any food down on their stomach
until they had had their methadone what
is methadone methadone is a synthetic
drug that was instituted in or
introduced in the 19 early 1970s to
block a heroin addict's craving for
heroin in an effort to cut down on
burglary and theft that was being
conducted by heroin addicts
it was felt that if we gave them a
synthetic drug
that would block the craving for heroin
then that would have a substantial
impact on and reduction on crime how do
you take it orally and you take it in
front of a nurse because there also is
an illicit hero
methadone market
so the nurse has to see you swallow it
you have to stand there and drink it
down in front of her
so that she knows that you're not
holding it back and then taking it
outside the clinic to sell
can what would happen if if someone who
doesn't take drugs took methadone would
it give you a high
i don't know i really don't know um
i think it would be kind of dangerous uh
because it's it has the effects the same
it is it
methadone in it of itself is addictive
people get addicted to it and can't get
off of it or are reluctant to get off of
it
in a number of hospitalizations that
rosalie went through at howard
university hospital her doctors talked
to her about getting off of methadone
then weaning her off in methadone but
she didn't want to she saw it as a
replacement for her heroin addiction
and it didn't she no longer now had to
go out and steal and hustle
to get the money for heroin because she
could get the methadone free
so she saw it as a maintenance drug
how did she get aids
she got age either through prostitution
or sharing needles with four of her
children
she uh
four of her
eight children were drug addicted uh two
daughters and two sons
in terms of heroin use intravenous drug
abuse
and one of the daughters also was
involved in prostitution
and the oldest son was involved in male
prostitution bobby the boy that died of
aids in 94.
and she shared drugs she shared needles
with all of them and she either got it
directly herself
from her prostitution
or was passed on to her by sharing
needles in inter intravenous drug abuse
you say that she had
eight children by six different men yes
married only to one of them yes
when did he die
he was just killed in 93 he was killed
by a woman who had a long history of
crack addiction
in a relationship that they had where he
would pay her for sex
and she beat him to death with a hammer
she was later convicted of murder and
she's now in prison for the for albert
cunningham's death
you say that in spite of the fact she
had eight children by six different men
she also had a lesbian relationship
exactly um rosalie rosalie she had a
lesbian relationship began in 1972 when
she moved into an apartment federally
subsidized apartment complex called
clifton terrace
and she met a young girl she was then in
her early 30s she met a woman who was in
her was 18 years old lucky
and established a relationship with
lucky and then lucky moved in with her
and her eight children and lived with
her for three years
and
what i got out of that was rosalie was
very needy
emotionally needy and any man or any
woman
who was willing to pay attention to her
and give her the love and affection that
she felt was missing in her life
was welcome any person like that was
welcomed in her life
you paint i don't remember what this
scene was but i remember i think it was
rosalie
who was having a sex relationship with a
as a prostitute in the bed with her
daughter next to her exactly when her
daughter was growing up um rosalie would
have her tricks she worked in a
nightclub called the cocoa club which
here in washington
was located at 8th and 8th street's
northeast
and oftentimes males the male customers
would approach her for sex
when she was getting off from work and
she would tell them very boldly
well i have eight children at home and
so be clear on what this relationship is
and i will need money from you tonight
and often when she came home patty was
in the bed in her in uh rosalie's bed
how old then
uh this went on it started when patty
was about five years old and continued
until patty was about 10 years old
and
rosalie then would have sex with the
customer
and
patty would wake up in the course of
this and watch the whole thing
was there ever a time when a sex partner
wanted to have sex with their daughter
exactly well when patty was 11
rosalie prostituted patty with an adult
customer of rosalie's
a man who she knew as a regular customer
came by and asked her one day
could he have sex with her daughter
and rosalie went then and approached
patty and asked patty would she be
willing to have sex with this adult man
the man was in his 40s and patty was 11
years old
and patti agreed because her mother had
asked her to she felt that
when patty first told me about that she
felt that she was helping her mother
bring income into the house because the
man was willing to pay
twice as much to have sex with her than
to have sex with her mother which was
somewhere in the area i could never
really pin down the exact amount but it
was somewhere between the area of forty
or fifty dollars to have sex with patty
twenty to twenty five dollars to have
sex with rosalie
patty had also at this point had been uh
had gone through three years of sexual
abuse by two male relatives she'd been
raped at age eight by a male relative
who had continued to rape her
uh how was the male relative at the time
the rapes began he was fourteen she was
eight
and also an adult male relative who was
in his 30s
raped patty on a number of occasions
and
all this had occurred even before she
was 11.
did any time in this process did you
just say i can't take any more of this
no i understood what i was getting into
i understood the studies have done about
the sexual abuse of children
ron minsey over at the
director of poverty programs for the
ford foundation had done a study at the
urban institute
where he looked at
the children that were going into foster
care and what kind of communities were
they coming out of
and when he correlated the
the
statistics it was
the children that were suffering
the most from uh familial uh sexual
abuse neighborhood sex abuse
psychological and emotional abuse or
just neglect were all coming out of
underclass urban areas so we're very
clear and i knew that going into this
project
i didn't know that
this i would run across it in this
particular family but i did i ran in all
in all the ills that i've run into
or read about in studies on the
underclass
were encapsulated in this one family how
many underclass are there
uh today there are over three million
about 57 percent of that 3 million is
black twenty percent is white twenty
percent is hispanic
and the remaining three percent is uh uh
asian american or native american what
do you define as underclass a family
that is female headed
chronically unemployed the adults in the
family ages 18 to 65 are chronically
unemployed
marginal educational achievement
throughout the family
welfare dependence
and criminal deviant
or criminal deviancy running through the
family criminal recidivism going in and
out of prison continually
a major supplement to the welfare
dependence being criminal activity
your full-time job
i'm a reporter with washington post on
the investigative desk at the washington
post how long have you done that since
1984 but i've been at the post for 30
years
where'd you go to college i graduated
from howard university in 1968. studying
what a major in history and minor in
political science where did you grow up
in new york city in harlem and the bronx
what was that like
it was great
i didn't
know that there was another life until i
left new york at age 21
and now i have no interest in moving
back to new york but i grew up
traveling on the very crowded subways
and
engaging in uh
life in new york which can be hectic and
contentious
uh
thinking that this is what the world was
like so didn't know there was any
difference until i left new york but i i
still have a lot of fondness for new
york what did your parents do my father
is was a postal clerk when i was young
when i was a teenager or a young boy
and eventually became a supervisor in
the post office and my mother was a
visiting home nurse in fact she visited
uh in new york's for new york city
health department she was a registered
nurse and she
started out visiting welfare mothers to
help them look after their young
children
and she eventually became a supervisor
in the new york city health department
my brothers and sisters one younger
brother he's nine years old he works for
ibm in san jose california are you
married
no married and divorced two children how
old are the kids my oldest daughter is
34 i have a five-year-old grandson and
my youngest daughter will be uh is uh
16.
now who in your life affected
the direction you took how did you end
up in journalism how did you go to
howard i went to i went into journalism
because i was interested in that
actually i had ended i was a transfer
student at howard university i started
out at lincoln university in
pennsylvania and while i was there i was
the editor of the school newspaper and
that and i took a course in journalism
at lincoln and that sparked my interest
in journalism
and then i transferred to howard because
i wanted to do
a wide range of courses in african
studies which were not available at
lincoln but were available at howard
and at howard after i graduated from
howard and i took these courses in
african studies i joined the peace corps
and went off to live in kenya east
africa
for two years 69 and 70
and was a rural high school teacher in
kenya
now i think those two years have had the
most dramatic impact on me because there
i lived with
the nandy people who were pastoralists
cattle herders and uh they lived on
homesteads and not in villages so they
were long distances
between the homes in a at an elevation
6000 feet above sea level which was on
the equator but the temperature was
moderate all year round always temperate
all year round
that's where kenya's great runners come
from all the kenya's get great runners
come from that area of kenya the western
escarpment of the rift valley
and i think that that had the most
dramatic impact on me in learning
another culture
and beginning to understand that culture
is relative
for instance when applied here
when you're talking when i talk with
colleagues and friends
a lot of people who are in my social
circle
everyone assumes that middle class
values are
universal and they're not the middle
class dominates american
life and american culture but our values
are not universal as uh as is very
is particularly uh
shown with rosalie's family
her family lived by a different code
a different value system value system
that said anything
is acceptable for survival even
prostituting an 11 year old girl when
did she first rosalee
first shoplift
she was a teenager
she was about 13. she shoplifted a
gray skirt
and a white blouse
to work as an usher in the family church
mount joy baptist church on capitol hill
here in washington
she wanted a stylish skirt skirt and a
stylish blouse
to work as an usher in her church and
she knew her mother wouldn't
wouldn't
from from rosalie's viewpoint her mother
wouldn't buy her those kinds of things
but from my viewpoint her mother
couldn't buy her those kinds of things
her mother didn't have the kind of
income that rosalie felt that she had so
mother did all of the shopping at
second-hand stores in washington
second-hand clothing stores and rosalie
didn't want her mother buying
any second-hand goods for her
to wear
when she worked as an usher at the
family church so she shoplifted
successfully a skirt and a blouse we
were looking at a picture that i want
you to identify here that rosalie is
there on the right
who else is in the picture on the left
is far left is ducky her youngest son
and in the middle is her daughter patty
talking on the telephone but what ducky
and rosalie are doing are examining
goods that ducky has burglarized from
someone's home
because they're taking them that morning
to the mcdonald's that i would meet her
at
to sell them to other to other people
who on methadone maintenance
women men and women that rosalie
referred to as her drug buddies seldom
hot
how much
did she steal in her life and i know you
talk a lot about this in the book and
how much about the rest of family did
they all shop
well she taught all of her children to
shoplift but only two rejected that very
early on as children alvin and eric
the two sons who have never been
involved in drugs or crime
and i mentioned them alvin works as a
station master now in the metro rail
system that's him when he was still a
bus driver and eric works for the u.s
park service
uh but rosie did a lot of stealing i
mean she had her first sentence for
stealing 19 days in a juvenile
institution when she was 15 and pregnant
with her second child
and that did not stop her
she stole
a lot you even would travel to do
shoplifting traveling to new york city
traveling to baltimore out of washington
she did her first long sentence in the
mid-1960s how often did she go to jail
uh
for both for stealing and for
drunk offenses 12 times
in her lifetime what was her longest
nine months her longest sentence or her
she was sentenced to a year on a number
of occasions but she never did more than
nine months and you say out of the eight
children only two
have never been involved in crime on
drugs
did you talk to those two quite a bit
alvin and eric i was trying to figure
out how they were able to avoid this
because alvin is the third born child
and eric is the fifth born child
so they had children that were ahead of
them in between them and coming after
them who got involved in drugs and crime
but these two avoided it
and it came down to uh alvin and it came
down to a period when they were very
young and both of them were in
elementary school
alvin had a reaction of shame and
humiliation when children would tease
him at richardson elementary school
about the fact that his family was
welfare poor
his family lived on welfare and how the
children knew that
in those days they weren't food stamps
and the welfare a welfare truck would
come once a month with surplus federal
food for welfare families
and distribute that food only to those
families that were on welfare and alvin
was so ashamed of this that he would
always run away whenever the truck came
and blew it on he knew the horn when he
heard the horn he would run run away
from the house
because rosalie would then send all of
her children out to the truck to bring
in their allotment of surplus government
food and alvin didn't want to be seen
carrying the real life bags because that
clearly identified the family as welfare
poor and that's how ashamed of it he was
or what made him ashamed when did he how
he learned well the children were
teasing him about being welfare poor and
that developed within him a class
consciousness because these children who
were teasing him were not on welfare why
didn't they affect the others that way
the other children i have no idea
they didn't collude they didn't share
this information as children when i was
interviewing eric months after i
interviewed alvin
i talked to eric about
alvin's shame and humiliation about the
welfare food truck and eric act reacted
with surprise and he said he was ashamed
i didn't all this time i thought that he
was lazy
that that's why he ran away when the
truck came
so he didn't know what was going on with
alvin nor did alvin know what was going
on with him
eric had a reaction of anger and disgust
toward his mother he loved his mother
but he also was very angry with his
mother
because when when it came he's three
years younger than alvin when he started
when he entered elementary school the
children started teasing him about his
mother stealing
how did the children know that because
the parents of the children were buying
rosalie's hot goods from her they would
all troop over there in the evenings and
buy shoplift goods that had been
shoplifted that day from rosalie with
the price tag still on it and pay
one-third the price or even less than
that
and would talk about it openly in front
of the children so the children then
began teasing eric about the fact that
his mother was a thief
and that infuriated eric and he did a
lot of fighting at school because of
that and he even fought big kids much
bigger than him and if he couldn't beat
them he'd grab a brick and hit them with
it and that's how angry he was about it
and he confronted rosalie as a child
and said to her people are telling me
that you're stealing things why are you
stealing things and she told him
well
there are eight of you and the welfare
check i get for you is not enough to
feed you or to clothe you
and to take care of you for one month
and he said but you get a check i don't
understand if you get a check i then
don't understand why you have to steal
to add money to the check and she gave
him the same explanation
and when he asked her again she just
chased him away and said boy that's what
i do to take care of you and that was it
but both for alvin and for eric these
initial feelings on alvin's part of
shame and humiliation about living on
welfare
and
for eric
anger and disgust with the stealing
both of that both these reactions set
the seeds for them to reject
the lifestyle that the rest of the
family adopted
and and they were fortunate or perhaps
they were receptive
that they later on in their early teens
picked each of them picked up a mentor
that stayed with them for about 20 years
alvin in the eighth grade gartrell
franklin his history teacher became his
mentor at evans junior high school and
for eric nancy mcallister a social
worker became eric's
literally alvin
literally and eric literally both
attached themselves
to these mentors because they were
looking for some kind of guidance like
most children look for and they weren't
getting it at home did you talk to these
mentors oh yeah talk to both of them
quite a bit and they remember these two
yeah they're still in touch with them
they still interact with them not as
much or as intense but there's a bond
and a friendship there
that is lifelong
why did these folks talk to you
all of them the whole family and were
they ever worried about their peers um
no not really and i interacted with
their peers too i mean it was there were
stolen goods passing in front of me
there were drug transactions going on
around me i watched them do drugs i
watched them smoke crack i watched them
shoot up with heroin
if i was going to be there then i had to
be part of all of that and eventually
they did all of that very openly in
front of myself and the photographer
lucian perkins
but um
rosalie when i approached her initially
had just come out of the most
harrowing
withdrawal from drug addiction when i
met her in the jail in january of 1988
she had come into the jail at previous
october she had been arrested at the
corners of 14th and w streets northwest
selling heroin while babysitting
three of her grandchildren
and she was selling the heroin both for
her addiction and to get enough money to
feed her three grandchildren because the
mother of the three children her
youngest daughter also
at that time was in jail uh on a drug
address on a drug arrest
and um when she went into the jail they
don't give you anything in the jail to
help you to ease your withdrawal from
the drug
and she didn't think that she was going
to live
and she had gone around to her jail
counselor the man who eventually
introduced me to her francis henderson
wanted to talk to henderson about her
life
and henderson said to her
well rosalie i've got you know i've got
you and i've got a
you know 90 million other people in my
case though i really don't have time to
talk to you at length about your life
but there's a reporter here who's doing
just that sort of thing and i'll
introduce you to him so he put the two
of us together
and i told rosalie i did a nine day
my first interview with rosalie lasted
over nine days just to put her life
together she was then 51 from the first
day from her earliest childhood memory
up to that point in her life january
1988
that first interview i said was nine
days and then
in the course of those nine days she
said to me
i want you to tell my story every every
part of it because i'm hoping that
other people who read it won't take the
steps and take the path that i have
taken
and i said to her i said well i don't
think the people who need to read your
story for that reason will read this
story
they won't be they'll be involved in
their criminal lifestyles and their drug
addiction and so on
and so they really won't be interested
in reading the story and her reaction
was that's okay you write it like i tell
it
i said fine and i said this is going to
take some time she said i don't care how
much time it takes
so
given my relationship with her which
developed in which began in dc jail and
when she came out in may of 1988 i began
then to follow her outside prison
she in over a period of time introduced
me to all eight of her children
and told them what i was doing and that
she was participating and she wanted
them to participate and they initially
were wary but after a while
i just became to them a part of the
family a person who came in and out
regularly interacted with them and
called their past and their present
what was the worst situation you ever
found yourself in the day that rosalie
took a shot of heroin in front of me now
she had told me
about this um
there was a period it was a 14-month
period where she was not using heroin
and
this was after she had gone back to
heroin use and
i didn't expect her to use heroin this
day and i wasn't prepared for it and it
was very painful for me to watch
when she took the shot of heroin her
daughter patti
injected her in her left calf
rosalie was lying on her stomach on her
bed and i was in front of rosalie's face
on the other side of the bed sitting in
a chair
and rosalie looked
at me
our eyes locked just when she got the
shot of heroin
and
i thought that i had effectively
covered my reaction and masked it so
that no one could see how i was feeling
but she later called me at work and told
me that she would never take another
shot of heroin in front of me and i said
why i mean
you um what you do is up to you rosalie
doesn't have anything to do and she said
don't tell me that buddy
i saw the look in your eyes and i'll
never take another shot of heroin in
front of you she ever described to you
what you actually know but that's all
she had to say i already knew what i was
feeling
i had thought i had covered it that the
facade
was the objective and distant reporter
but obviously she had looked deeply in
deeply enough to know better what kind
of drugs did she take in her life
amphetamines that's what she started
with in her lesbian relationship she
started relatively
late in life she started using
amphetamines
at the age of 36 and it was introduced
to them by her lesbian lover as a way to
keep her weight down
then after her
lesbian friend and her broke up she was
in a lot of emotional pain and by this
time patty who was 16 was a heroin
addict and
suggested to rosalie that she used
heroin to get over the pain
of the breakup of the relationship
and patti rose
in
1975 and
she enjoyed the feeling
it did
the pain
did evaporate and
thereafter she became a regular daily
heroin user what's it cost today
that period was relatively expensive
compared to today then it was 40 dollars
a billy billy is a quarter teaspoon of
heroin
today it's down to for the same amount
of heroin and the with the purity higher
it's down to ten and fifteen dollars um
so it depends on the size of your habit
your habit can require as rosalie's
required maybe three
forty dollar billies a day which is a
hundred and twenty dollars
uh but if it is the same habit today
could cost
cost you as little as 30 to
40 dollars how do you take heroin
some people snort it in the powdered
form that's usually how people start
and eventually
they they switched to intravenous uh
drug use injecting it in a vein
because it gets to the brain and the
pleasure centers that much faster how
long does that billy last
oh it can last depending on the purity
of the heroin
uh six to eight hours where do you buy
it
uh in any drug market rosalie herself
ran what are called oiling joints in
clifton terrace
oil joint is where heroin attacks go to
shoot up their heroin either to buy
heroin or if they bought it on the
street they take it to an oil joint to
to inject it and the process of
injecting is called oiling so that's
where the name oil joint comes from and
you can if you don't have an hypodermic
needle in the tourniquet you need to
wrap up your arm to have the vein
pop out you can rent them at the oil
joint of course these things are not
sterilized so it's a very easy way very
uh um
it allows for the transference of the
aids virus using oil joints and using
the equipment at oil joints
uh quite easily
was it rosalie that used her
five-year-old grandson the granddaughter
five-year-old granddaughter in the
summer in 88 when the
uh her youngest mother the the child's
mother her youngest rosary's youngest
daughter was in jail
rosalie was selling heroin again at the
corner of 14th and w street's northwest
the place that she was arrested before i
met her and was using her five-year-old
granddaughter to ferry the heroine two
customers
a customer would come up to rose lee to
buy a 40 billy that's what the price was
in 88
and
uh rosalie was signaled to the
granddaughter
to go get a billy and the daughter would
go to a place where the
heroine was hidden
and then bring it to the customer and
the customer would pay rosalie
how much of that were you able to see
yourself i didn't see any of that
why well bob woodward then my supervisor
uh supervisor of the investigative desk
at that time
felt it was too dangerous that we would
be exposing myself and rosalie to
retaliation from the drug lieutenants
who surround the heroin market but don't
keep any drugs on them
but are there to protect their
investment
and
the drug trade is a very violent trade
and if they thought that i was an
undercover policeman or if they found
that i was a reporter i also wanted to
try to station a photographer where he
could get photographs of this
woodward felt that was all too dangerous
how often was lucian perkins a
photographer with you
very often but he developed his
relationship independent of mine uh the
photograph that you showed
for example of rosalie going through the
stolen goods i wasn't there that day
so rose
rose lee and and her all of her children
became quite accustomed to to lucian and
lucian could go in and out of the house
and observe and be
be there when they engaged in any
activity without them really aware that
he was taking photographs i mean he
became over the four-year course of the
project like a fly on the wall
did you excuse me did your coverage of
this family result in any kind of arrest
after was over no none that one should
they have
followed up once i mean would the police
read the i mean when was his first
publishing
september eight part series in september
of 1994.
what happened to rosalie after that
she became a minor celebrity
in terms of going around doing a lot of
talking both at drug rehabilitation
centers and at different churches in
washington
and uh
agencies that were involved with women
in prison and women who were criminal
recidivists and drug addicts
in fact
there's a humorous point i wanted to
make
she
was telling me about
speaking at all these churches and she
told me one day
that
the after she talked people would come
up and press money into her hand five
and ten dollar bills
and i said well how much money have you
collected uh going around speaking at
churches
and
rosalie said uh why do you want to know
that and i said well i'm your agent you
know i get 10 percent of everything you
collect and she laughed and said well
then you'll never know how much money
i've collected
there's a picture and it's
the family church down in chapel hill
north carolina
you wrote down with her i took her there
i went and looked for her family first
in april and then i took her down there
to meet her family in june this is where
the the family that stayed behind when
her parents and grandparents migrated to
washington family that she had never met
i went down and looked for them in april
of 93
and found them and uh found the whole
all the family that stayed there all the
relatives who had stayed there
and they all asked me well why don't you
bring rosalie down here so we can meet
her and the cousin said she can come and
stay here with me
and so um i went and told rosalie that
and she was kind of skeptical at first
because she had been there once before
when she was seven
and she remembered that she stayed in a
grandparents sharecropping shack on the
bishop and power plantation and she
remembered that there were no outhouses
and there was no toilet paper and that
the house had no
caulking in between the boards and the
wind blew right through it and
all these for her were terrible memories
when she had gone down there for that
two-week period
in the 40s
she had sworn to herself if she ever had
a choice she would never go back
and when i first approached it with that
i said i found relatives of yours in
rich square north carolina and
they were like they'd like you to come
down and visit and i'll take you no
problem
and she said i don't want to go down
there and i said why
you know her reaction was so negative i
was surprised and i said why don't you
why don't you want to go and she said
well you know i was down there when i
was a child and they don't have any
outhouses or anything they don't have
any tolerance but i said all that's
changed rosalie she said oh no no it
couldn't have changed that much i said i
was i was at you i was at two
of your cousins houses and they all have
indoor plumbing now
and is uh what you're what you're
reacting to existed in the 1940s but
they all live in substantial houses now
one cousin has a brick house and an
elderly cousin her grandmother's first
cousin a 90 year old woman lives in a
substantial wood frame house
and she
said okay but she was still kind of
skeptical until actually we got to the
cousin hilda lawrence 10. we got to her
house and we pulled into her her yard
and kilda has a big ranch-style
tan brick home
and she said oh it's a lot different
because she was thinking of the
sharecropping shack or sharecropper's
shack with the rusty roof tin roof and
and the gray board planks with uh
where the wind could blow right through
the house that's what that was her image
of that area and she had no desire to
stay in a house like that again
rosalie cunningham
got how much
public assistance how many different
programs that we hear about all the time
came to her well she was on
aid to families of dependent children
the oldest program and since uh
is that welfare
welfare
there's general welfare then there's
afdc aid to families of dependent
children and she
started on that in 1950 when her first
child was born and
she didn't get off it
uh
in between trips to the prison but she
didn't actually leave the welfare roles
until 1990 when she turned over
three of her grandchildren to the oldest
to the youngest of her daughters
who had then had a year of recovery from
heroin and crack cocaine addiction and
wanted to take her children
responsibility for her children herself
and have the afdc check transferred to
her then rosalie entered
the social security program of
supplemental security income because she
was hiv positive and considered
medically disabled
so when she left the
welfare role she went on to the social
security roles
public housing public housing what did
that mean
well that meant
that you had housing that
was at least intact
in terms of she we went to we visited
all 18 sites where she lived and some of
the buildings were still standings the
ones that were still standing there were
not public housing were boarded up in
fact even one of the public housing
projects that apartments that she lived
in uh we went to uh that also was
boarded up because the deterioration
from the lack of maintenance had set in
but the private housing was all slum
housing what would she pay
for public housing oh uh as little as 28
a month what would she pay for private
housing
uh that same amount just about
one of the houses we went to you she
said from the third floor you could see
from the third floor to the basement the
top floor was three stories up but you
can see all the way into the basement
through different parts of the houses
because the floors in the house had
deteriorated so badly
and she only paid in the 60s during the
riots in washington in 1968 she was
living there and she was paying
something like 23 a month for that house
three-story row house fruit stamps
or food stamps since the program began
in the 60s in the late 60s public
housing food stamps fdc ssi all that all
of that we missed anything there you
said the the the trucks would show up
with the surplus food before food stamps
brought in yes
a federal of um spam
uh cheese
beans a lot of pinto beans she said
when she needed drug money you say that
she would finagle all this stuff
somewhere in the aid or the medicaid uh
assistance that she also received
medicaid that would be the local versus
the national medicare right uh well no
medicaid is for the poor medicare's for
the elderly but there's no more state
involvement with the medicaid it is
right and she would use her medicaid
prescription card to buy
darvon and zainex
and 120 pills at each
purchase and it would only cost her 50
50 cents for each prescription but then
she would sell the pills for two dollars
each
to fellow drug addicts who came to the
mcdonald's after they got their method
on because a lot of them ex they said i
have no idea if this is accurate uh that
they experienced a high
if they took darv on xenax or both right
after they took their methadone
how close did you get to her
fairly very close i mean after the
series ran in 94 i dissolved a
professional barrier i had maintained
between us
and was willing then to act as an
advisor and a friend
though she started calling me at home at
six in the morning and i had to tell her
i said to chat because the methadone
would wear off about 4 30 5 o'clock in
the morning and the methadone clinic
didn't open until 7 30. so for those two
hours bef when she woke up when the
methadone woke wore off and she always
had abdominal pain
when the methadone wore off
and until the clinic opened she was wide
awake and with nothing to do
there wasn't a lot on television at that
time in the morning that she wanted to
watch so she would call alvin her son
that she was closest to or call me
and i said well rose you know at six
o'clock in the morning it's not the best
time in the world
to call someone to chat
you may be wide awake i am not please
call me in the evening uh and she got
into the habit of calling me about 9 9
30 at night because that's when her
favorite programs
went off television and she generally
went to bed by 10. when did she stop
prostituting
i think in the
early 1980s
and she said essentially is because she
had lost her looks
she was too old people were men were not
interested in buying sex from her she
had reached
she had crossed over into an age group
in her late 40s that she could no longer
successfully prostitute how old was she
when she died
58.
what year did she die again december i'm
sorry july 1995. and where were you when
she died uh i was at home i had seen her
july she had been in the hospital she
entered the hospital on april 18th this
is significant
it's the same day that one of her
grandsons a 15 year old grandson there
was a funeral for him that same day the
same day she entered the hospital he had
been killed on a
in a shootout in his community that grew
out of rivalry between two groups of
boys called crews
over the drug trade the fourth street
crew that rico leon cunningham was a
part of and the linden pollen crew
and rico her 15 year old grandson was
driving a car with another one of his
buddies in it and they tried to
assassinate
a boy from another crew who was driving
a lincoln town car
that boy retaliated and killed both rico
and the other boy dante hammond
and that was on april 11th 1995. rosalie
called me at home that evening
when the phone rang i didn't think it
was her because it was so early and i
picked up the phone and was her and she
said
mr dash rico is dead
i couldn't believe it i had now known
rico since he was eight years old
now he will here he was at 15 he was
dead i said what are you talking about
she said yeah he was killed in a
shootout this afternoon he's now his
body's over the d.c general hospital
so that was a lot to swallow then a week
later was his funeral
and that morning i went to the funeral
and didn't you get the pulitzer right in
here
that day
that morning i went to the funeral
rico's funeral which was a very there
wasn't a dry eye in the place it was
very painful
um funeral everyone was upset um as you
can imagine and i was upset i had known
this boy since he was eight when he was
gregarious open child
and uh i had watched the transition into
the criminal lifestyle that he was
involved in
and there wasn't anything to do to stop
it uh he wasn't listening to anyone
and now he was dead and here he was in
this casket and when i went around the
funeral home and i was looking for
rosalie someone told me
rosalie went into the hospital at four
o'clock this morning suffering from
pneumonia an ambulance took her
so this was her about 18th
hospitalization since i'd known her
for both age-related illnesses and drug
overdoses so i wasn't
alarmed i didn't think that
i had seen her just a couple of days
before
and she seemed strong and healthy and as
feisty as ever so
i went after the funeral and the funeral
and the wake
and the burial all took place one right
after the other the same day
i went to the office and by that time
the office was a buzz with a rumor that
myself and lucian perkins had won
a pulitzer
for explanatory journalism
and of course that came across the wires
that afternoon
the newswires and then there was an
office celebration which i didn't feel
you know i didn't it was a sort of mixed
feeling i felt ambivalent about the
whole thing
because i just come from rico's funeral
to here i wasn't really worried about
rosalie at that point
but i still had that
i still had some emotional pain from the
funeral
and here i was supposed to be
celebrating winning a pulitzer so it was
an odd day for me
well right after all the celebration
died down i left and went over to howard
university hospital
i went up to the receptionist and said
um
uh which room is rosalie cunningham and
reception said and looked it up and said
oh she's in intensive care
and intensive care she had never been in
intensive care
and so i went up to intensive care and
they had this big sign only family come
in so i stood outside the glass door but
she had her mouth they had a breathing
apparatus
and a tube in her in her strapped around
her mouth
and they were pumping oxygen into her it
was very obvious so i knew then that she
was fighting for her life well she never
left the hospital live she
she did get off the respirator and did
regain consciousness
and i did we had a number of
conversations during that period she was
in the hospital from april 18th to july
7th
the last time i saw her was july 4th
and she was unconscious and i couldn't
wake her when i went to see her in the
hospital
and so i knew i had already seen her son
her older son deteriorate in the same
way from age bobby at the same hospital
howard university hospital
and
that was july 4th the last time i saw
her
july 7th
at 7 30 in the morning her son eric
called me at home and said
mama died at 2 30 this morning
and then her funeral was a week later
and i went to the funeral july 15th
what'd you think of her i liked her
i thought that she had made some very
bad choices particularly the
prostitution of her
oldest daughter
that was a horrible choice and um
almost
almost unforgivable
but there also were things that the
things that she did
that she thought were her only
opportunities
for day-to-day living she didn't see
herself as having a lot of choices or
particular avenue of opportunity for the
future
her life was always governed by what was
needed today
never tomorrow
she always existed in today tomorrow was
a far
far off place
that she might get to and might not
who's this gentleman that's rosalie's
oldest grandson
rocky lee brown jr his nickname is
junior
he is in prison serving a 15 to 45 year
term for
his second armed robbery conviction when
did this happen
oh
the arm actually the armed robbery took
place in february of 94. the second
armor robbery have you seen him oh yeah
uh and i'll be seeing him again soon
he's now 24.
uh i saw him in january
uh i just recently saw his mother who
also was in prison it's panic that's
patty yeah what do you talk to when you
see these folks i ask them what are they
doing well patty and i talked about the
fact that she's moved into full-blown
full-blown aids now this is a picture we
have here of patty and her mother right
how old was she here by the way uh that
was taken
uh she's
we determined that she's 38 now
that was taken when she was about 34.
and
what's her life like now well she's in
prison and every day is a struggle just
to get out of bed
because she's weak and feverish often
how many children she have only one she
had junior uh were there any abortions
along the way
foreign did two back uh backdoor uh
abortions with coat hangers
um when she had she had junior when she
was 14
and
she
uh
had junior essentially because she
wanted to be a woman
and she felt that having junior at age
14 would move her from the status of
adolescent to
adult who are these two that's two of
rosalie's sons that's the oldest bobby
on the right and richard her fourth born
son on the left both of them inside the
dc jail together at the same time in
june of 1991. he said bobby was a
homosexual yeah
and
how old was he when he died 43.
what caused all this
uh
poverty
ignorance
one of the most significant things for
me in rosalie's life is that she
attended dc public schools up until the
seventh grade
and she was illiterate
she had never been taught to read
how many of her eight children
graduated from high school
uh none
alvin who is the station master now with
the metro rail system got a ged in the
army
and went on to do college study
but
he's the only one
you have two daughters yes one sixteen
one sixteen one four thirty four thirty
four right you talked to your own
daughters about this oh yeah quite a bit
what do they do
uh my oldest daughter is a physician's
assistant
and
mother of five-year-old son
and my youngest daughter is in 11th
grade at east chapel hill high school in
north carolina what do they think of
what you do
i think they have mixed feelings about
it
because
a lot of people particularly middle
class black people
are defensive about
looking in depth or in detail into the
lives of the black underclass because
they feel the society the larger white
society in america
will describe all of this behavior
to all black people can you find whites
living the same way oh yes yeah 20
percent of the underclass is white
that's the main name rule population but
with drugs
oh yeah prostitution right criminal
abuse of children prostitution of
children everything
uh
but the the middle class blacks because
of the legacy of um
racial oppression in the united states
and the argument by some whites
that
blacks are genetically predisposed to
this behavior middle class blacks are
very defensive about this particular
aspect of black life
the black underclass
and
one more emphasis put on middle class
achievements
i understand that
leon dash is our
author guest for this book notes and the
cover of the book looks like this and
that's a picture of rosalie cunningham
and her son bobby both now deceased yes
thank you very much thank you
leon dash won the pulitzer prize for
explanatory journalism in 1995 for the
series of articles upon which rosalie is
based the book is available in paperback
from dutton plume an imprint of penguin
putnam